yeah there's something about PTSD that
obviously uh an amazing record of yours
that was on your last album yeah
um but it's something about PTSD that
you know we always think of soldiers
having it people who go to war but I
think that you know people who have been
through certain situations or grew up in
certain places
is very real man and it's like
have you tried to uh
have you ever tried to [ __ ] with
mushrooms at all no I ain't gonna lie
you know what's so crazy bro like long
ago I always wanted to try like like
years ago I always wanted to travel and
I used to be around juice all the time
I'm saying like I always wanted to try
that [ __ ] I ain't gonna lie but I never
tried it because I just feel like I need
to be in a set space you know what I'm
saying be in a set space Maybe out the
country with my family having fun and
I'll maybe try that [ __ ] you feel I'm
saying but I always wanted to try it
though when you do it you definitely
have to have your guard fully let down
yeah
my brother I swear my brother told me
this story look this my brother's name
G2 he an artist he signed the South Side
that's my brother hello he told me one
of his experiences of shrooms and this
is what made me want to try yeah he came
in the studio I wasn't there he came in
the studio crying like crying everybody
like what's wrong what the [ __ ] you
crying for and they said I'm happy he
said I'm crying cause I'm so [ __ ]
happy in that [ __ ] threw me out I
started laughing so oh [ __ ] hard when
they told me that story and that's what
made me want to try stroke well like uh
there's
um
PTSD ins like specifically yeah
psilocybin which is the psychoactive
ingredient that are in magic mushrooms
you know whatever
um it cures it for soldiers well so
mushrooms though yes so in Portland so
in Portland but I'm saying like and
that's crazy you said that because G2 is
Street [ __ ] yeah that's what I'm saying
like it was a different feeling for him
like whatever the psychedelics also I
mean obviously it depends on how much
you eat depends on what you know what I
mean but in uh so they just legalized uh
psilocybin therapy in Portland so like
now like there's like soldiers who will
just go to Portland for like two weeks
that's correct and they'll go see a
therapist and they do like some
psilocybin therapy and man it really
helps the therapist get them shrooms
there yes but they give it yeah and it
helps with it really helps with PTSD
well just like a form of the trolls
basically yeah like Joe Biden just
talked about legalizing it for
therapeutic purposes because it helps
BTSD that's crazy
MDMA therapy which you said that I'll
probably have to try it you have to man
and you have to do it you have to do it
like
make sure the kids ain't around yeah for
sure you can do it recreationally and
like be in the studio and still kill it
you know like I [ __ ] was Friday the
other night I never tried it but I want
to try it though I'm not but you gotta
do it if you really want to do it
because I think if you really like PT
first person to ever really introduced
me to shrooms with South Side South Side
I already was [ __ ] with the trolls
he's [ __ ] with everything yeah
yeah this is a party pack Sizzle is that
guy when it comes to just me my brother
no he's a great great guy me and him had
one of the funnest interviews I've ever
done and I appreciated this transparent
that's really like my twin brother he's
a great guy I wanna you know the one
thing I haven't done is party with them
and I'm not sure I want to but uh yeah
you you you're not gonna want to but you
guys don't know if I'm ready I don't
know if I'm ready that [ __ ] literally
me and him uh like
he's hilarious man yeah I didn't know
what to think yeah I'd met him before
back in the day and he came in for the
interview and he was just like an open
book and he's hilarious yeah super solid
exactly it's like he's solid but it's
like it's a whole other like
sad tool yeah they don't make it like
they don't make him like him he'll make
them like well I'm telling you like
that's my that's my best friend bro like
my mother loved him his mother loved me
like I know his whole family he know my
entire is amazing you know my whole
family I know definitely do the
mushrooms man yeah I think mentally
it'll help you man but you should do it
one time but like listen look they're on
the back like hey man I don't know why
you want to introduce this y'all
first of all it's not a drug it's not a
drug you could do your research on it
but get an Airbnb somewhere
in the [ __ ] Woods away from
everything exactly and try it eat a ton
and then just sit back and let it let
the medicine do its work but you know
this go crazy because my mind
automatically like I I'm a thinker bro
my mind is like all over the place like
literally I think about sober I think
about every single obstacle in my life I
think about okay I make this decision
it's gonna affect this person this
person is always then you're am I cool
with that all right I'm cool with that
I'm gonna do it you feel that's how I
think automatically so I know shrooms
gonna open my [ __ ] up a different way
like even more even the smallest thing
like weed when I used to smoke weed bro
yeah I used to think differently you
know what I'm saying like when I drink
liquor I think differently but I'm a
thinker you know I never act off
emotions mushrooms will just sings a
certain way increase the thinking
exactly and I've heard it that's what
I'm saying yeah
I'm a natural thinker so I can only
imagine what my mind is going to do if I
take a shroom
I got you man I own a gummy company so
yeah I'm gonna hook you up we're gonna
[ __ ] around I'm gonna hit you I'm gonna
hit you about it after I tried I'ma call
you you're gonna be the first person I
call like hey bro I'll [ __ ] with you for
that yeah you're gonna like you're gonna
close your eyes to go to bed the night
you try them and your brain and then
y'all see it President Joe Biden already
then God damn it the goal is to leave
legalize uh psychedelic therapy and then
before you want to say to Joe Biden
right now
I don't know you old as [ __ ]
we miss Obama we miss Obama